[Music]
[Applause]
get big fast the Mantra of amazon.com
and its boisterous founder Jeff Bezos
from the moment I got there the feeling
was that you just pressed down on the
accelerator harder and harder the
audacious entrepreneur rewrote the rules
of retail there really was this sense of
urgency around this internet land grab
that was taking place how do we
establish the Amazon brand his strategy
didn't always pay off even after Amazon
went public people looked at the
financials and said this company's not
going to make it amazon.com
profitable in December 1995 it must have
been for oh about one hour
with a series of Sly moves Jeff Bezos
built and rebuilt amazon.com if you ask
a question that Jeff doesn't feel like
is something they want to go into the
answer you get is going to be the laugh
[Laughter]
and he's laughing all the way to the
bank
you can buy anything at amazon.com from
books music shoes and clothing to a
battle tank or a tiki hut
Amazon is the most successful online
retailer in the world and still run by
the man who created it back in 1994 Jeff
Bezos
Jeff seemed to realize that being the
singular place where a consumer can find
and buy virtually anything that's
available in the retail Market was a
critical part of the company's growth
strategy
the public image of Jeff Bezos is of a
superhero entrepreneur and he is that if
you look at his life from the very
beginning he's taken risks and he's
solved problems and he's created
billions of dollars wealth Bezos is more
guarded than his outgoing public Persona
and declined to participate in this
program
Jeffrey Preston Bezos was born in
Albuquerque New Mexico on January 12
1964 to Jackie guys a 17 year old high
school student
guys divorced his biological father and
married Miguel Bezos a Cuban immigrant
and petroleum engineer for Exxon
Miguel adopted four-year-old Bezos in
1968.
Bezos described his early computer
experience in a 2001 interview with the
Academy of achievement there was a
company in Houston that had loaned
excess Mainframe computer time to this
little Elementary School none of the
teachers knew how to operate this
computer nobody did but there was a
stack of manuals and me and a couple of
other kids stayed after class and
learned how to program this thing
as a teen Bezos embarked on his first
serious entrepreneurial effort a summer
camp based out of his house with an
emphasis on science and literature five
students signed up at 150 a pop
in 1986 he graduated from Princeton
University summa [__] laude with degrees
in electrical engineering and computer
science Nicholas Carlson is Deputy
editor at businessinsider.com and has
covered Amazon for six years Jeff
Hazel's actually recruited into a hedge
fund named D.E Shaw and he didn't want
to work in finance he actually wanted to
work in computer programming but D.E
Shaw is a computer programmer and the
hedge fund is sort of built around
algorithms and the type of technology
that Bezos is interested in
it wasn't the only thing he found
interesting
He Came Upon A statistic that just
astounded him he saw that the internet
was growing at two thousand three
hundred percent per year and he just
became obsessed with this number
studying the top 20 mail order
businesses Bezos saw an opportunity
online
Chris Anderson is the former
editor-in-chief for Wired Magazine he
could see that there was this
technological tsunami that was arriving
that was going to disintermediate it was
going to create new distribution
channels reset economics changed the way
we bought and sold and the question was
which domain shall we apply it to
the answer was books a commodity for
which no comprehensive catalog existed
in July 1994 he quit his secure Wall
Street job to pursue his dream
to create one of the world's first
online bookstores
his First Investors his parents who he
talked about with the Academy of
achievement and my dad's first question
was what's the internet okay so this he
wasn't making a bet on this company or
this concept he was making a bet on his
son in the summer of 1994 Jeff Bezos and
his wife Mackenzie headed to Washington
State armed with three hundred thousand
dollars from his parents
entrepreneur and Technology expert
Esther Dyson is Chairman of the
investment firm Adventure Holdings you
now have a lot of people leaving Wall
Street to go
try and do startups but Jeff was
different he had a really solid
business slash Wall Street background
and then he created something amazing
Bezos and his wife settled in Bellevue
Washington and hired two programmers to
write the code Bezos related the story
in a speech at Lake Forest College in
1998. I found a house that could serve
as the first business and it had a
garage and it seemed the right thing to
do since there's a history of startups
and garages this wasn't fully legitimate
because it was a converted enclosed
garage but I considered it somewhat
legitimate because it wasn't insulated
those were not impressive offices he
dubbed the company Amazon after the
seemingly endless South American river
with its countless tributaries
on July 16 1995 amazon.com opened its
virtual doors to the public James Marcus
was employee number 55. Marcus was hired
to write book reviews for the site that
was nothing more than a list of titles
when I checked out their site to see if
this was a place where I might want to
work I discovered it was quite
rudimentary actually there was a front
page with an Eclectic mixture of books
but the most notable thing was that
there was a huge catalog of probably
several hundred thousand books at the
time but there was no content in that
catalog the fledgling amazon.com had no
advertising budget initial sales were
generated solely by Word of Mouth
Heath Terry is a managing director at
Goldman Sachs there was a lot different
about Amazon really from the beginning
you know they weren't in Silicon Valley
they were in Seattle they weren't really
into the whole hype of the bubble they
weren't putting out press releases every
single day the site caught on within a
month books had been sold to customers
in all 50 states and 45 other countries
what was different about Amazon was that
Jeff rennick right he was organized he
understood distribution he understood
how to motivate people to buy he just he
did things with great attention to
detail
Bezos goal for growing the company could
be summed up in a simple line get big
fast was both a mantra and very much a
strategic decision on Jeff's part
everything had to be on steroids all
growth had to be on steroids Eric best
was manager of Business Development at
Amazon from 1999 to 2001. there really
was this sense of urgency around
capturing e-commerce market share this
internet land grab that was taking place
you know how do we establish the Amazon
brand and grow the overall business at
the expense of competitors and within a
very time-bound window
the strategy paid off big time
by the end of 1996 the company reached
15.7 million dollars in sales the gains
were boosted by Amazon's ability to
offer tax-free shopping to most online
consumers what makes us different is
vast selection convenience we deliver
right to the desktop and also the fact
that we're the broadest Discounters in
the world we discount over 300 000
titles basically the best selling titles
that's twice as many titles as the
largest physical bookstore even offers
[Music]
but early investors were frustrated the
surge in sales came without profits
while Amazon spent Millions developing
software and expanding its business you
know there was a lot of risk that was
taken on by the company during those
early days and I think there was a lot
of speculation around whether or not
that was the right thing to do it's easy
now to look back and say of course
Amazon needed that capital and they
needed to invest at the rate that they
did in order to achieve the scale that
they now have that was not always clear
from day one
what was clear was that Bezos was
Unstoppable
he kept up the pace and powered ahead
for Amazon's IPO
the idea was that you could not rest on
your laurels for one moment and that you
just had to keep innovating all the time
and staying ahead of the competition all
the time and never have even a
millisecond of complacency
[Music]
on May 15 1997 the stock began trading
on the NASDAQ stock market at 29.25 a
share nearly 12 dollars higher than its
offering price the day of the actual IPO
was a very big deal there were you know
parties all over the company and Jeff
addressed us you know over the
speakerphone from New York I mean Jeff
was telling us on the phone you know
we've made history today you have all
made history today it was pretty damn
exciting
but despite the well-received IPO Tech
analysts still offered a dour assessment
of the company
Tim O'Reilly is founder and CEO of
O'Reilly media most people remember the
business store is that Amazon was going
to be toast people were scrutinizing
their financials they were saying this
company will never be profitable or
there were a lot of naysayers the
company's Engineers were hard at work
updating the site introducing features
like one-click shopping
by the end of 1997 the value of Amazon
stock nearly tripled Jeff would say to
us do not pay attention to the stock
price
he was very confident that in the long
run it would go up and up and up but
felt it was very dangerous to look at it
in the short run
Amazon continued their frantic expansion
hiring more than 7 000 employees and
beefing up their product line you know
we just heard talking about virtually
everything and anything we could sell
groceries Health Care cell phone plans
and cell phones magazines and then
eventually you know hardware and garden
hoses and toys
the expanded product line and high
volume sales paid off for both
amazon.com and Bezos
on December 20th 1999 he was anointed
Time magazine's person of the year made
my mom cry and you know parents are
always proud and that feels great it was
the the ultimate legitimization of his
sort of Starry I dream of Conquering the
world through e-commerce like you flip
to the inside of the magazine there's
Jeff dresses Indiana Jones swinging out
a Vine it was kind of making him into an
American folk hero in a way it's like
you suddenly like Paul Bunyan was in the
office down the hall from you
Bezos was at the top of his game but an
industry-wide disaster was right around
the corner by the late 90s amazon.com
was an online Juggernaut but in 2000
the.com Bubble Burst
stock prices slumped and Jeff Bezos was
forced to take drastic measures so there
were at least two waves of layoffs and
as is usually the case for these things
you don't know who's going to go you
kind of cower in your office and wait
for the HR person to you know summon you
with a finger and it feels bad to see
your colleagues go in the context of the
slowing economy and the uh the the Deep
slowing and consumer confidence this was
the only prudent decision that we could
make
by September 2001 the company's stock
hit an all-time low and bottomed out at
5.97 a share
from poster child to Whipping Boy and in
nanoseconds it's not the kind of stock
that you can own and sleep well if
you're a small investor and I think by
the way that's true of all internet
stocks the advantage that Amazon had was
they had built this war chest so to
speak on their their balance sheet of
cash to to fund them through all this
Jeff Bezos made a lot of large bets and
not all of them paid off the company
didn't profit for many years in the
beginning the reason Jeff Bezos got away
with that and benefited long term is
because he was always very direct with
employees and stakeholders in the
company
at long last by January 2002 those bets
began to pay off
Amazon's stock price rebounded and Bezos
company did something it hadn't done in
seven years posted a profit the best
thing can say about him is that he was
unwavering in his confidence he could
see the bigger picture and he knew that
the Skeptics were were short-termers
they were not seeing the big picture and
he stuck to the vision once the bubble
burst the Investor's patient for
companies saying we're going to make big
investments in building out a.com side
to our business was very very thin and
so Amazon took advantage of that and
started partnering with Target and Toys
R Us and the Gap and other traditional
retailers the.com retail giant joined
forces with more than 400 companies but
not all retailers were willing Partners
I do know of a number of cases in which
he has acquired companies in order to
take out competitors potential future
competitors rather than because he
actually wants that business to continue
with his company back on track Bezos
switched gears and increased his focus
on a much different passion
on March 6 2003 he charted a helicopter
to Scott property in a remote region of
Southwest Texas
he was looking to buy up ranches for a
venture he had started in 2000 called
Blue origin
blue origin is a technology company
whose purpose was to develop vertical
takeoff and vertical Landing rockets for
human space travel
the trip was nearly a disaster
shortly after takeoff the helicopter
flipped and landed in a riverbed
in 2003 Jeff Bezos almost died in a
helicopter crash
it's sort of a pattern where he can go
through something difficult like a.com
crash be philosophical about it laughing
off with his big famous laugh
unlike space exploration Ventures
bankrolled by private backers including
Elon Musk Richard Branson and John
Carmack Bezos is obsessive about keeping
his efforts at Blue origin secret for a
variety of reasons it's pretty secretive
and I think actually from the point of
view of the space industry that's sort
of a Pity what makes
a good market is when you have a bunch
of competitors openly competing and they
try and position themselves against one
another and the Market's visible they
compete for money they compete for
people and so forth
after six years of working behind closed
doors and locked Gates blue Origins odd
looking test rocket blasted off
[Applause]
Bezos was also set to launch on another
revolutionary effort this one closer to
home this is an opportunity to hugely
expand the book industry expand pricing
expand the definition of what a book can
be but it required someone with
sufficient clout to do that end-to-end
Hardware software web integration and
only Amazon was in a position to do that
on November 19 2007 Jeff Bezos took to
the Charlie Rose show to announce the
release of a groundbreaking new product
here in my hands is what we're talking
about it is called the Tyndall tell me
when you first had the idea that this
might be possible what we realized at
the time was that there were a few
technologies that were sort of
converging that we could combine
together with the right recipe and make
something that would be what we hoped
would be transformative in the world of
electronic reading
the Kindle was an instant hit Amazon put
this device out there that takes away so
many of the aesthetic Pleasures that
people take in books you know you can't
smell the pages anymore dog ear the
books but it turns out Book Lovers who
are all these people that feared and
loaded this thing now they love the
Kindle the 399 dollar e-reader sold out
Nationwide in just five and a half hours
the number of Kindles sold however
remains a closely guarded secret a
company spokesman said that they choose
not to disclose the number Jane Friedman
is former CEO of harpercollins and
co-founder of Open Road integrated media
no one today knows how many Kindles
there really are out there it's a
guessing game we know that there are
millions but how many millions but it's
strategic for Amazon obviously because
that's what they do they keep a lot of
information close to the vest
but Publishers saw the Kindle as an
industry killer there will be real blood
on the tracks of publishing in the next
few years because Publishers did not
wake up soon enough to the fact that
Amazon was a competitor
compatible
while the Kindle was making serious
waves in the e-book Marketplace Amazon
Was preparing to make its largest
corporate acquisition to date Tony Shea
is CEO of zappos.com America's leading
online shoe retailer when I first met
Jeff Bezos in 2004 he hadn't contacted
us and said they were interested in
possibly acquiring Zappos at the time we
said we weren't interested because
Zappos would kind of lose its identity
Shea was hesitant to sell to Amazon they
contacted us again and said they were
willing to consider a different scenario
where we could remain independent and we
started realizing wow they might
actually be really great Partners Amazon
purchased the hot online shoe retailer
in the summer of 2009. Zappos investors
received 10 million Amazon shares worth
about 1.2 billion dollars at the time
the deal closed I got stock which at
this point is better than cash and what
this kind of shows is that Jeff Bezos
and Amazon is someone who yes he can
steamroll the competition when he needs
to but he's also willing to play ball
and negotiate and get what he wants but
make everybody wealthier in the process
the shoe fit but is Cash Cow the Kindle
was about to get some very serious
competition from a Tech Giant and we
call it the iPad on January 27 2010 a
Apple launched the iPad also designed
for use as an electronic reading device
Bezos responded aggressively by cutting
costs and adding new features to his
e-reader one thing that Bezos has always
been comfortable doing running Amazon is
playing with very tight margins so when
you see the Kindle lowering in price
what you're seeing is Bezos recognizing
what the real long-term gain here for
Amazon is to be the place where everyone
buys all of their ebooks and the Kindle
is just how they get them
the phenomenal growth of the e-book
Market devastated bricks and mortar
stores
Allen came on the scene and became a
competitor to the bricks and mortar
retailers and they were the tailor
everybody was coexisting in fact borders
and it may have been their downfall but
borders did all of their digital their
digital selling through Amazon had
borders established its own presence it
might have been a very different
situation today
according to the author's Guild Amazon
had been buying books from Publishers at
12 to 13 wholesale and selling them as
Kindle books for 9.99 taking a loss each
time
best-selling author John Grisham railed
against Amazon's pricing model we're
going to get to a point if a book is
worth ten dollars okay whether it's a
discounted hardback at Amazon or an
e-book sold by Amazon for the Kindle if
we're ten dollars okay then suddenly the
whole industry is going to change you're
going to lose Publishers you're going to
lose bookstores others saw opportunity
you look at all of the authors that have
been kind of empowered by Kendall to
develop a direct consumer relationship
that they never had before and I think
that's where Amazon is able to come out
a winner in all of this by building this
bridge between authors and their readers
that in the past has never really
existed
Borders Books filed for bankruptcy and
Barnes and Noble the largest bookstore
chain has been struggling
in 2011 amazon.com stepped beyond the
retail sales market and into the video
streaming ring going head-to-head with
Netflix Andrew wallenstein is a TV
editor for variety magazine I think if
your Netflix you're looking at Amazon
and really sizing them up as a
competitor Amazon has a lot of traction
online they've got Deep Pockets to buy
just as much content they're at the very
beginning of this kind of effort but in
time Amazon could grow to be just as big
as Netflix the e-commerce retail giant
is also fending off growing efforts to
put an end to its untaxed online sales
several States now require Amazon to
charge local sales tax
but Bezos remains cool Under Fire and
unfazed he continues to forge ahead now
Jeff Bezos has his fingers in
everybody's pie he's got video streaming
which competes with Netflix he's doing
music now which competes with apple and
iTunes he's even selling Android apps in
an amazon.com app store that goes right
after Google's Marketplace if he sees
something where Amazon can make a little
piece of money and help its margins
which are you know so thin he'll go for
it going forward has gotten him this far
his space project is going even farther
in April 2011 NASA awarded blue origin
22 million dollars to continue
developing its space vehicle design
he was listed by Bloomberg as the 20th
richest person in the world with a net
worth estimated at 25 billion dollars
amazon.com Remains the world's largest
online retailer he's not just a
Visionary with visions he's an architect
with blueprints and some notion of how
to make things work he thinks very
carefully about design and structure and
operations and that's what turns a
Visionary into somebody who actually
accomplishes something
he could have sold Amazon to Barnes
Noble or probably to some other book
sellers and walked away with many
millions of dollars like in his early
30s since then
he just keeps on coming up with really
good ideas
he's not the hard charging going to take
no prisoners type CEO
he's somebody that has his vision for
how he wants to build this company and
is able to surround himself by people
that buy into that I think ultimately
that's one of the reasons that he's been
as successful as he has
[Music]
Reed Hastings seems as tough as his DVDs
practically indestructible he has
transformed the world of movies TV and
cable twice we rent DVDs it's a flat
price it's really easy he's one of the
people that killed the video store oh we
would have liked nothing better than to
bury Netflix he defied his critics and
bet his company on movies by mail when
DVDs were a novelty most investors were
just convinced Netflix was just
another.com it was a you know a nichy
little idea people didn't want a
subscription and it would never take off
it took off and flew high for 12 years
its value climbing to 12 billion dollars
before spectacular stumble stalled its
growth Netflix subscribers are fleeing
on mass more than 800 000 customers
canceled their service last quarter I've
heard some people say that it feels like
aliens have taken over his body Hastings
is determined to restore his company's
reputation and is Zone he comes across
as sort of typical Silicon Valley
executive very low-key but you know he's
one of those guys who has to win 10 12
years ago when we started Netflix you
know the internet was still AOL dial up
but realized wow networks are just going
to grow and you know what's going to
happen all video is going to become
click and watch internet video
Everything
Reid Hastings has made a career out of
anticipating the future first in a
software tool then with the simple DVD
and a 32 cent stamp you won't find
anybody who has more Drive than Reed
Hastings he's always thinking about the
Strategic shifts that need to be made he
is an incredibly focused Innovative
individual that is like smart like light
years smart he's one of those guys who
doesn't like to talk about himself a lot
but who really feels like his actions
show you know how good a company he can
run
true to form he declined to talk about
himself for this program as well
Hastings was born in Boston
Massachusetts in 1960 and grew up in the
suburb of Belmont former Governor Gray
Davis is a friend of Hastings he came
from a middle class background his
father was a lawyer did not come from
great wealth education is the reason
he's successful
educational success included a
bachelor's degree from Bowdoin College
in Maine he spent one summer in a
training program for the U.S Marines but
realized the military wasn't for him
instead he joined the Peace Corps where
he taught for two years then hitchhiked
across Africa with 10 bucks in his
pocket
teaching was inspiring as he told
Charlie Rose in this 2005 conversation
well I was a high school math teacher
originally out of college in the Peace
Corps in Swaziland and I love teaching I
love I've taught high school math and it
was just a fantastic experience
returning to the U.S he got a masters in
computer science at Stanford and landed
a job at a technology company called
adaptive Corporation Mark box is a
startup investor who was introduced to
Hastings at the dawn of a new era in
computer programming he said you know up
until this time every program that's
been created has been created in the
head essentially of one person but now
we're kind of getting to the point where
it takes two three five ten guys to
write a program and so as that starts to
happen you have problems coordinating
between the people and that creates lots
of Errors errors Hastings thought he
could fix he wrote a program and started
a company with markbox called Pure
software like all perfectionists
Hastings wanted to hire the best and
quietly did whatever it took to get them
akifujimura was then an experienced
software manager at Cadence Design
Systems I didn't want to leave the
company that I was with but then he came
over to my apartment with a six-pack of
beer and we started talking and that's
his typical style Audrey McLean was one
of Hastings First Investors and a board
member once we got going there was no
stopping it the company doubled year
over year for four years in a row so it
was an absolute rocket ship
by 1995 pure software had reached the
Holy Grail of 90 startups going public
on opening day the stock shot up 75 it
was a very exciting IPO in fact we were
the most successful IPO of the year in
1995 for one week the following week
Netscape went public and they eclipsed
it the success landed Hastings on the
front page of USA Today in front of his
flashy new Porsche Carrera a photo he
would come to regret Cliff Edwards is a
technology writer for Bloomberg
businessweek I think he felt like it
sort of portrayed him as a sort of Rich
whiz kid living the dream when in fact
he really wanted to show that here's a
company that he is nursing to health and
and is is pouring his life into two
years later he sold the company for 750
million dollars and turned his talents
in a very different direction Michael
kirst is is a professor emeritus of
education at Stanford University I got a
call from somebody I'd never heard of
named Reed Hastings saying he wanted to
come to Stanford and study State
education policy and politics and I
wasn't quite sure why he was interested
in this because it didn't fit in with
anything on his resume
for Hastings it was a new start
for six months he studied hard then went
to the state capitol to advocate for a
new kind of school in California and he
was able to successfully create one of
the first laws in charter schools in the
country so it allowed Innovation and new
operators to come in and was really an
entirely New Concept for California
[Music]
there was a New Concept for Hastings as
well
a familiar annoyance prompted Reed
Hastings to reinvent an industry in
1997. he recalled getting a 40 late fee
for a movie rental in this 2005
appearance on Charlie Rose I remember I
didn't want to tell my wife about it and
I thought oh great now I'm kind of
compromising the Integrity of my
marriage over this late fee so of course
I did tell her about it but it made me
think I can't be the only one who is
struggling with this late fee thing and
just started me thinking about the
internet and DVDs and how something
could work without late fees the movie
rental industry made around 8 billion
dollars a year nearly all of it from the
dominant format of the day VHS cassettes
Hastings saw the opportunity in a new
format and a surprising new business
DVDs by mail but first he had to find
out if the discs could survive the U.S
mail so I stuffed a bunch of CDs and
they couldn't buy DVDs that put them
mailed them to myself and then I had to
wait for 24 hours to see him come home
uh to see are they going to be all
shattered in a bit along with the my
idea and then you know the next day at
three o'clock the postman arrives that
rip opened the envelopes and the first
one's in good shape and the second one's
in good shape and the third one's a good
shape but I'm like the sucker is gonna
work
in 1998 Hastings launched Netflix as the
first online store to rent DVDs current
Redbox president Mitch Lowe was a
co-founder we started in an old Bank
building in fact our inventory was in
the old Vault there's about seven or
eight people everybody was dedicated to
figuring out how to do something
disruptive in the entertainment
distribution business they stocked up on
DVDs from retailers like Best Buy but
there was a problem
less than one in a hundred households
owned a DVD player they cost nearly six
hundred dollars and no one knew when
they'd become more affordable he
committed everything to DVDs if DVDs
didn't happen he's got you know the
company's nothing it's zero
Blockbuster and Hollywood Video
dominated the industry with thousands of
retail stores in almost every
neighborhood if Hastings wanted to
compete he had to build a better
customer experience
so he innovated with an idea an easy to
use subscription service for a monthly
fee members were allowed as many movies
as they could watch with no late fees he
realized having to resell the customer
every time is a bad idea on a three
dollar transaction and he eventually got
the company to go to the subscription
model and I think that changed
everything for him that change was
boosted by two popular features the
queue a list of movies that the user
wanted and computer-generated
recommendations that were surprisingly
accurate Michael pactor has followed
Netflix for 10 years as a research
analyst with web Bush Securities the
internet ordering mechanism and
interface was Innovative the
recommendation engine was Innovative and
the queue was Innovative and I think
where Netflix really thrived early on
was they were first to figure all this
stuff out but for all their Innovation
Netflix was still barely on the radar
their revenues of 5 million at the start
of 2000 vanished and next to
Blockbuster's 4.5 billion 900 times the
size of Netflix
in a bold and clever move Hastings went
for help to his biggest competitor
everybody loved Blockbuster and
Blockbuster was The Golden Child and
Netflix was sort of this ugly uh step
child that was coming up and everybody
thought well this thing's not going to
last it's not going to have legs it's
gonna die we were having challenges as
far as acquiring customers and we saw
Blockbuster as the greatest single
source for rental customers so we
actually reached out to Blockbuster and
invited them to become a strategic
partner and and an investor Blockbuster
the entertainment giant found it
entertaining
John antiocho had been Blockbuster's CEO
for three years when Netflix Came
Calling we thought well if we're going
to get in this business we probably
shouldn't give the internet rights to
another company for a couple percentage
points and that's what caused us to keep
evaluating whether we wanted to enter
the business or not I think that you
know Netflix was was very lucky that
Blockbuster who was the Sleeping Giant
at the time didn't do anything and they
stayed asleep his reed is a gentleman I
think if you had a different CEO at
Netflix it was a little bit cockier and
a little bit more brash
I think that Blockbuster might have been
provoked into competing
there didn't seem much reason to compete
by the end of 2000 Netflix was
hemorrhaging money their losses
skyrocketed to 57 million dollars it
just sounded like another.com idea you
know like e-toys and most investors were
just convinced Netflix was you know a
nichy little idea people didn't want a
subscription and it would never take off
while Netflix was struggling to become
profitable in 2000 Reed Hastings did the
unexpected again he took an additional
job on California's state board of
education any of you have tried to
change large organizations know that
half the battle is getting it on the
right course the second half of the
battle is keeping it on that course he
was appointed by then Governor Gray
Davis you know I was ever in a foxhole I
would like to read Hastings with me
because we would have discussions about
the next school board meeting and we
would argue over what that decision
would should be but once you know we've
kind of came to a decision yeah he went
in there and he held his ground and he
got the reforms established
Netflix on the other hand was anything
but established and heading into the.com
dive how the mighty have fallen
according to a recent study by Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter the average Internet
stock is down two-thirds from its
52-week High
having long planned to go public Netflix
filed preliminary papers as the market
spiraled down we faced a lot of
obstacles in the first IPO attempt the
bubble had burst there was the belief
that the business that internet
businesses had no substance behind them
there was the anthrax scare there was 9
11. it was just like the perfect storm
of everything going in the wrong
direction
Hastings canceled the IPO
in October 2001 Netflix had to lay off a
third of the company Netflix was on the
brink of disaster I think that between
1999 and 2002 Netflix could have
gone under at any time had serious
competition arisen
as the year was closing Hastings got the
break he needed the price of DVD players
plunged and Hastings slipped a coupon
for a free trial of Netflix in nearly
every new box business took off
[Music]
with the company back on track the much
delayed IPO became a reality in 2002
Netflix went public
the stock Rose 12 percent the first day
to 16.75 but it was a double-edged sword
Keith Terry tracks Netflix as the
managing director of Internet research
at canacore genuity going public got
them a lot of attention not just from
consumers but also come from competitors
and so they were going to start seeing
pretty significant competition from
companies like Walmart and entrenched
players like Blockbuster
Walmart launched its competing service
in 2003 a year later Blockbuster also
jumped in we initially launched kind of
the same way Netflix did which is free
trial membership you know one of the
most beautiful words in the you know
American language is free and that was
getting us reasonable growth
Blockbuster's monthly fee was also two
dollars less than Netflix igniting a
nasty price War
Netflix slashed its price Blockbuster
countered Walmart edged under both so
Blockbuster cut to Rock Bottom
in a conference call on the end of the
year earnings Hastings declared
Blockbuster has thrown everything but
the kitchen sink at us quite frankly
myself and a couple of key members of
our management team were sitting in my
office listening to the conference call
someone said well
why don't we send them a kitchen sink I
said good idea next day we shipped one
out at that point the Rivalry was
definitely established
the fierce competition on multiple
fronts took its toll Netflix stock
plunged 75 percent
analyst Michael pactor commented that
Netflix is a worthless piece of crap
with really nice people running it I was
convinced that Blockbuster would compete
effectively and so it seemed to me that
if Blockbuster was determined to retain
its customers then Netflix would
disappear Hastings wasn't going down
without a fight
he sacrificed prophets to drive back the
competition and maintain the company's
growth
it became a war of attrition The View
that you had out there was that Netflix
wasn't going to be able to survive uh
this this level of competition from a
lot of people and that Blockbuster and
then Walmart were ultimately just going
to squeeze the profits out of Netflix
and I think what both companies found in
pretty short order was this business was
a lot harder than they thought
while the battle with Blockbuster and
Walmart raged Reed Hastings suffered a
personal setback for four years Hastings
had championed Public School Reform on
California's state board of education
but when he pushed for more English and
bilingual programs he was pushed out by
Democratic Representatives it was a blow
to him and it was surprising and it was
I would think somewhat even humiliating
to be turned down by your own political
party
but he said if this is the issue that
you want to kick me off the state board
about then I go proudly with my head
held high Hastings focused his attention
on his company's battle for the DVD by
mail business and in the middle of 2005
the tide began to turn
Walmart pulled out giving Netflix their
rental customers in exchange for
promoting their sales Blockbuster was
gaining subscribers but losing hundreds
of millions of dollars
now it was Hastings turn to call someone
nice we're not against Blockbuster
they're all nice people they're but our
goal is to offer a better service that
consumers prefer us to them and that
eventually that does result in them
closing in 2007 at the Sundance Film
Festival in Utah
antiocho said he was called to a private
Summit with Hastings to explore the
possibility of a deal his preference
would have been for Netflix to buy
Blockbuster online and what we proposed
back was a merger it never got Beyond
talks because of concerns about
antitrust regulations
by 2008 antiocho was gone and
Blockbuster backed away from its online
business they lost hundreds of millions
of dollars trying to compete with
Netflix and they just didn't have the
cash to keep up competing at the level
and you knew at some point they were
going to have to give up and ultimately
that's what happened
it was a Triumph for Netflix but no
sooner had Hastings secured the movie by
mail business then he launched a new
service that would mean the demise of
the DVD
Netflix delivered its billionth DVD in
2007.
Hastings was about to reinvent his
company with a service that promised to
make DVD by mail obsolete
streaming video online
[Music]
it was what he had foreseen from the
very beginning of Netflix it just took a
decade to arrive if there's anything you
would want to bank on it's the
technology will keep making bandwidth
faster and cheaper bandwidth may have
been cheaper but not the shows
themselves unlike DVDs Netflix needed a
license for every movie it streamed and
fees were astronomical Andrew
wallenstein is an editor for the
Hollywood News Daily variety I think the
kind of titles Netflix first started out
with streaming was probably the bottom
of the barrel it was kind of the the
movies or TV programs that were long
forgotten not the best stuff I remember
making you know a mocking comment and a
research note about how no one wanted to
see Revenge of the Nerds 3 when it was a
new movie back in you know the early 90s
so they certainly didn't want to see it
in 2007. even if they did Netflix could
only stream to one device the personal
computer we don't watch movies on our PC
he's going to stream to the PC who cares
and we thought it was nuts we really
thought he was nuts so Hastings offered
the new service to subscribers for
nothing and when he then announced and
we're going to provide this for free we
were sure he was nuts
he pursued even more content adding 11
000 titles in less than two years and
finally he secured a breakthrough deal
for First Run movies and shows I think
you'd have to go back a few years to the
deal that they struck with stars which
enabled them to get some great films out
of the Sony Library the Disney library
and they only made that deal for
something like 20 million dollars which
in retrospect was the steal of the
decade
deals followed with many of the major
Studios
it's my pleasure
pleasure more impressive was how rapidly
Netflix expanded the world of streaming
to geek gadgets the iPad has been a
tremendous success for it and almost
every entertainment system on the planet
content and access drove phenomenal
growth by 2011 subscribers hit 20
million topping 2 billion dollars in
Revenue had grabbed the attention of
Industry goliaths Amazon Apple Google
and Facebook they're all 800 pound
gorillas and this is sort of the danger
point for Netflix if you're thinking of
any time where they may have faced more
pressure I can't think of one
surprisingly the real pressure for
Netflix didn't come from those other
Tech Giants but from a series of
spectacular self-inflicted wounds in
July 2011 Netflix announced that it was
Raising its monthly subscription fee 60
percent
800 000 subscribers defected two months
later a contrite Hastings apologized
we're making this video today to
apologize in person he went on to
announce that Netflix would split its
DVD and streaming businesses the price
increase remained but DVD by mail would
become a new brand quickster
the move fell flat customers and
shareholders continued to flee dumping
subscriptions and stock Netflix now in a
downward spiral was forced to backtrack
Netflix pushing the rewind button today
the company coming out with the big
flip-flop saying that quickster is dead
and that the DVD and streaming services
are back under one umbrella now the
reason for the reversal is simple
customers just didn't like it Hastings
delivered yet another apology this time
for moving too quickly quickster became
the symbol of uh Netflix not listening
and we quickly changed course on that
and we're going to stick with DVD as
part of the Netflix brand it was an epic
collapse Netflix lost almost two-thirds
of its value in three months including a
stunning 2.3 billion in one day and if
that wasn't enough bad news Netflix and
stars parted ways depriving Netflix from
newer films from Disney and Sony leaving
the impression that Netflix was losing
content as it raised prices Hastings
moved quickly and announced new content
deals with Dreamworks Animation
relativity AMC CW and others
despite the stumbles Hastings says he
never considered stepping down he said
he wants to be measured by the success
of 12 Years rather than the mistakes of
12 weeks I think Reed has changed the
way we all think about consuming
entertainment he's expanded the options
and the way you get movies I would not
count out Reed Hastings on Netflix I
think again that they are a company that
knows their challenges uh that they
don't hide from them there's very few
companies that have done this many
things and succeeded and you know 12
years later you know again it's one of
those companies where you may not like
the company but you can't argue about
its successes
[Music]
Richard Branson the man with the golden
touch and the billionaire smile he's
fabulously Rich famous as a rock star
and he always seems to be having a
really good time I've been
extraordinarily fortunate I've enjoyed
every minute of my life I wouldn't spot
my life with anybody
he's not impressed by wealth he's more
bothered but to have fun and do I have
excitement you've got to have the
balance Branson parlayed a sexy name
virgin into branding gold an astounding
300 plus goods and services from Rock to
air travel to cell phones to trains we
have taken on the big fat bloated
companies that have not really thought
too much about the consumer and we've
gone in and shaken them up if you'd
analyzed the risks that Richard was
taking you wouldn't take them there's no
risk analysis would say go ahead with us
to keep it all afloat Branson became his
own best pitch man living out the Virgin
values of Adventure and fun even if it
meant putting his own life on the line I
too seem to have conceived almost every
way known to man to try to kill myself
and I've been very fortunate to be here
today to talk about some of these
stories if such a title actually existed
Richard Branson might really be the most
interesting man in the world he owns his
own Island balloons around the globe
works with world leaders and he plans to
take a virgin submarine to the Uncharted
bottom of the ocean floor his riskiest
Adventure yet you only live once and we
accept that there are risks attached to
doing something that mankind hasn't done
before but we we go we go there with our
eyes open
Branson has spent much of his life on
the high wire of entrepreneurial risk he
has amassed a personal Fortune of more
than four billion dollars
I've never been interested in making
money I mean it um easy to say I suppose
people might say when you have made
money but I I've just been interested in
creating things and creating things that
I could be proud of and
um and you know having a lot of fun
creating things
Richard Charles Nicholas Branson was
born on July 18 1950 to middle class
parents on the outskirts of London his
father was a barrister his mother was a
former flight attendant severely
dyslexic he could barely read by the age
of eight and was hopelessly lost with
numbers
school was painful you know I'd look at
look at a Blackboard and wouldn't be
able to understand anything that was
going on
interestingly if you look at the history
of dyslexics they they often
exceed quite exceptionally because they
concentrate on the areas that they that
they're good at it certainly taught me
the art of Delegation from a quite a
young age Nick Powell was Branson's
closest friend and future business
partner I always thought with Richard
that he was going to make an impact on
the world you could tell
from a relatively early age that he had
qualities that were not common amongst
all the other friends that that we had
we used to play there sitting on either
side of the white line
and it was the last one to move when the
car came down the road Richard always
won the games a day but Branson had a
strong entrepreneurial streak when he
was 13 he tried growing Christmas trees
for sale he tried breeding parakeets
at 15 he decided to launch a national
student newspaper I worked out of a
phone box at my school ringing up
Coca-Cola ringing up you know people to
try to write for the magazine ringing up
Barclays Bank to try to get them to
advertise you know the accused of people
outside the phone boxes I was shoving
more money into the into the phone
the magazine student was an instant hit
with a circulation of fifty thousand
Graham Boynton is a former travel
reporter for the London Telegraph and
covered Branson for over 20 years
although he was a child of the 60s he
was always slightly awkward so I think
what happened was the business gave a
vocabulary a raise on debt and and
that's and he and he went from there in
1970 Branson started a mail-order
discount record company that he hoped
would raise money for the magazine the
first order of business was coming up
with a name somebody suggested slip disc
records we had the you know the old
vinyl desk which kept on slipping
um somebody else laughed you know why
not Virgin uh we're all virgins and
hysterical after all around
um and and I suddenly thought I am
virgin at business and you know I might
be a virgin at other things as well and
you know why not virgin
a postal strike in 1971 nearly
deflowered the mail order record
business so Branson decided to open a
record store one with headphones and
water pillows that catered to a younger
generation Simon Draper Branson's cousin
was his first record buyer and the
future head of Virgin Records everyone
was paid the same so this there was just
a kind of a feeling that no one should
be earning any more money than anyone
else but if you stop to think about it
it was actually convenient to have
everyone paid the same because it could
pay everyone less some of the people who
worked for Richard in the record shops
in in Notting Hill
they used to steal the records out of
the shops and they were absolutely
amazed when Richard fired them for
stealing he was wired to be a
businessman from from day one
five months after opening the Virgin
Store Branson was suddenly arrested for
tax evasion he was discounting his
records in part because he had figured
out a way to get around a 33 record tax
he spent a night in jail and his parents
had to put up their home to get him out
he thought that the part of the last
game was to avoid paying tax and I think
that must have come as a huge shock to
Richard he was extremely upset but he
behaved impeccably he carried the cancer
no one else uh
had any penalties
I had managed to avoid a criminal
offense by paying what the customs and
exercise needed and we expanded our
record shops very quickly so we could
get the turnover in order to pay you
know pay off the debt since then I've
made sure that we've done everything
ethically and you know without without
worry that someone's going to come
knocking on our door
to pay off a 150 000 fine and avoid
going to court and possibly prison
Branson rolled the dice on some new
Ventures including a recording studio
and a new record label which he launched
with his cousin Simon Draper
their first signing was an unknown
folkie named Mike Oldfield with an odd
instrumental album called Tubular Bells
well we're asking each other to take a
punt at what we thought it was going to
sell and I seem to think that I thought
it would sell twenty thousand copies
which seemed a lot to me at the time but
Millions later you know very different
story 16 million to be precise overnight
the record Put virgin on the map and
made Richard Branson not yet 23 a
millionaire Branson poured his profits
into new artists and Ventures but his
willingness to reinvest all his winnings
unnerved his Partners Nick Powell put up
so much resistance that Branson bought
him out I didn't believe we had enough
cash flow to sustain the expansion of
the company and I was wrong I'm willing
to double down maybe more than I
recommend to other people but there have
been occasions where I've got my wife to
sign this fitted paper and she hasn't
realized that the house has been put on
on the line for the next business lunch
by 1984 Richard Branson was living the
life of a rock and roll Kingpin he owned
this island in what else the British
Virgin Islands and Virgin Records was
one of the most successful independent
labels in the world
The Sex Pistols
Simple Minds
Human League Culture Club where all
million selling Acts
Branson was flush with cash and looking
for ways to spend it out of the blue an
insurance lawyer named Randolph Fields
called and asked Branson to back him on
a transatlantic Airline Simon and my
other poor Partners would be tearing
their hair out because you know suddenly
you know I was saying you know I hate
traveling on other people's Airlines and
we can do it better my shares
um which I owned at that time 15 of the
whole virgin group were becoming pretty
valuable as I was appalled and I said
this is the beginning of the end of our
relationship
Branson launched his airline with a
single used 747 that he leased from
Boeing the guy from Boeing said um you
know what did you say the name of your
company was I said well virgin
um you know where the people who brought
you the sex vessels the Rolling Stones
he just slightly jokingly said well you
know with a name like that you know we
hope your airline will go the whole way
um and um you know we'll we'll give it a
go
after buying Fields out of the
partnership Branson decided to offer an
upgraded mix of economy and Business
Class fares with a big emphasis on
Non-Stop fun
[Music]
virgin's inaugural flight from London to
New York set the tone
let me tell you it was a bacchanalian
orgy I mean it was wild there was
drinking there were topless models on
the plane it was aloe party and Richard
LED from the front
David Tate the first person Branson
hired was an executive with Virgin
Atlantic when the door to the airplane
opened at Newark it was kind of like a
champagne cork coming out of a bottle
because to this day I think there was
still a record number of champagne
bottles drunk on that flight over
with just one plane and one route
Branson's first problem was promotion he
didn't have the advertising budget to
compete with British Airways and the
other giant carriers so he took matters
into his own hands embarking on a series
of breathless ballooning and boating
Adventures that would quickly turn
Virgin Airlines into a household name
the beginning of a great adventure his
1987 flight across the Atlantic
fascinated world media for weeks
five people had died in earlier attempts
Pearland strand was Branson's co-pilot
put his life in my hands and
um
as they eased the balloon into the Irish
sea Fierce winds tossed them against the
waves
my Bella blueness and the more
experienced blueness jumped out of the
balloon
I was left in this balloon on my own
and the balloon spiraled up to you know
10 15 000 feet
so I'm in the water rich is in the
balloon he doesn't really know how it
works that was the scariest moment in my
life for sure
Branson managed to lower the balloon and
jumped into the freezing water
a royal Air Force helicopter fished him
out along with pair who nearly died
after swimming in place for two hours I
used to like to describe Richard as a
cross between Evil Knievel and Ted
Turner he'll always tell you that I'm
ballooning because it's great publicity
for the company baloney he's doing it
because he enjoys it if he were a cat
he'd be on his third set of nine lives
by the end of 1989 Richard Branson's
world was expanding on all fronts he
married his longtime partner Joan
templeman in a ceremony on Necker Island
the couple already had two kids
four-year-old Sam and eight-year-old
Holly
the company was also branching out
Branson had taken the Virgin group
public in 1986 with an IPO that
generated more than 56 million dollars I
don't think going public will make that
big a difference um to the way we'll
conduct our business that turned out to
be wrong it did make a difference
Branson chafed had been accountable to
an outside board and bought back virgin
after two years he now presided over a
small but precarious Empire with a
growing airline that was in constant
danger of going under and worse British
Airways was determined to crush its
upstart rival
the Rivalry between British Airways and
Virgin Atlantic has always puzzled me I
think it was down to British
establishment seeing this young upstart
with long hair sort of Reckless motor
Mouse Airline entrepreneur and it really
cheesed them off so much so that a 1991
British Airways launched with the Press
called the dirty tricks campaign they
had teams of people you know behind
closed doors illegally accessing our
computer information bringing our
passengers pretending to be from Virgin
Atlantic saying we had you know flights
that were canceled and switching them
onto British Airways they had people
going through my rubbish bins going
through the rubbish bins of our clubs
um you know trying to uh you know pick
up any any kind of dirt on us you know
they were placing stories in the press
and so on and so on most damagingly
Branson was convinced that British
Airways were stoking rumors that virgin
was insolvent and about to go under
will Whitehorn is the former head of
Virgin Galactic and has worked closely
with Branson since 1987. every day you
take off if you've got empty seats
you've lost money
so if somebody can persuade passengers
not to book with a certain Airline
because they think it's going to go bust
it will go bust
Branson was fighting to keep Virgin
Atlantic alive and once again he put his
life on the line to do it he took off on
another dangerous promotional balloon
trip this one over the Pacific
[Music]
in the middle of the Pacific we lost two
full fuel tanks
and we didn't know we had enough fuel to
make it do we have any jump
thank you
we knew that we had to fly this balloon
at an average speed of over 180 miles an
hour and that was just blown by the wind
and so the the chances of that happening
were extraordinarily unlikely
but we got right into the core of the
jet stream and suddenly saw the
speedometer going you know 150 160 170
180 190 200 210 220. I'm not a religious
person but it was as if somebody up
there had just taken that balloon and
was just pushing it pushing it through
the jet stream
Branson and lindstrand crash landed on a
frozen lake 300 miles from the nearest
habitation
we missed what we're aiming for by um
three and a half thousand miles and
landed in the Arctic in a snowstorm at
minus 60 degrees but we couldn't have
been happier in fact by the time Branson
thought out he was a superstar his
record label was heating up too Virgin
Records signed Janet Jackson and the
Rolling Stones to multi-year deals
but in the short term it was irrelevant
British Airways dirty tricks campaign
against Virgin Atlantic was making it
impossible to get credit to save the
airline Branson had to make the toughest
call of his life he decided to sell his
beloved record company Penny Pike served
as his personal assistant for 31 years
everyone was certainly shocked
I mean Richard was war shocked than most
people but she cried and cried she cried
it was a bit like selling a child I told
the staff burst into tears ran you know
ran down back towards my house with
tears streaming down my face you passed
this sign that said Branson sells for a
billion dollars
and I realized life wasn't wasn't that
bad he secured the future of Virgin
Atlantic because he had enough Capital
behind him after that to be able to look
any competitor in the face and say well
you know I can I you know I can sit this
out as long as you can people said at
the time we were mad to you know sell
the record company to put the money into
an airline as it turns out of course the
record industry's collapsed and the
airline industry hasn't done too badly
for us one month after the billion
dollar label deal Branson sued British
Airways for libel the airline settled
out of court and paid Branson a record
1.1 million dollars
we won the biggest rival damages of any
libel case
um and you know they had to make a
public apology
[Music]
oh Richard Branson was elated that day
was probably one of the great days of
his business career
he'd done it he stomped on the mighty
British Airways that night he was on the
phone to various people and he had this
real determination his voice that this
was the moment you know that he was
going to make Virgin Atlantic a global
success and he was going to take this
company and grow it around the world
after selling Virgin Records for a
billion dollars in 1992 Richard Branson
was ready to exploit his most valuable
asset the Virgin brand we suddenly
realized you know we actually have you
know something which is something we've
got to protect and we've got to nurture
the brand is ultimately is what what
virgin's all about Branson was the brand
and he tirelessly promoted it to date he
has virginized over 300 products and
services I think generally if you can
create something you can be proud of
it's likely to be successful
I wasn't thinking right let's just take
this brand into lots of different areas
I just felt you know we can we can we
can do better in health clubs we can do
better in mobile phone business
some Ventures like virgin Brides
and virgin Cola fizzled quickly then the
brand stumbled with Virgin trades the
acquisition came with a dilapidated
infrastructure and it took years to get
the trains to run on time
but some Endeavors have been
breathtaking in their success
in 1999 Branson struck Peter he
partnered with service providers to
launch Virgin Mobile they supplied the
network he supplied the marketing and
name and the Innovative idea of letting
customers pay as they go Bert Schmidt a
professor at Columbia University's
School of Business is an expert in
branding the value of a brand is really
in the intangibles because customers are
not just buying products they're not
just buying functionality they're also
buying an image they're buying a
lifestyle they're buying an experience
he stands for certain things he stands
for service for customer experience for
Innovation for fun
Branson was now business royalty and was
honored in 1999 by his country's royalty
he was knighted by the queen as a
millennium icon for his contribution to
Commerce
becoming Sir Richard did nothing to slow
him down
five years later he took Virgin Mobile
public with an IPO that he said valued
the company at 1.5 billion dollars
[Music]
Branson made each of his new Ventures an
independent company so that no single
failure could bring the Empire down
nevertheless analysts have regularly
questioned the value of the Virgin Group
which is still privately held the
headlines would be you know when's
Branson's balloon gonna burst and every
time we started something new you know
stretching the brand too thin and and
sometimes they went far off the truth
the Virgin group continued to spin off
new Ventures and in 2004 Branson
announced one of his most imaginative
he was going to take people into outer
space beginning with his own mother I
think we're within about 18 months of
going up into space and then starting a
whole new era of commercial spaceship
travel hopefully hundreds if not
thousands of people will be able to have
the chance to become astronauts and go
into space
it's a huge risk it's rather like
putting your name your brand on a
Formula One race car it's great when
it's winning but if it ends up wrapped
around a concrete pool somewhere then
then it has a lot of downside
Branson stretched the Virgin brand even
farther in 2006 with his own Airline
spewing tons of CO2 into the atmosphere
he pledged to spend all profits from his
Transportation companies over the next
10 years an estimated 3 billion dollars
to fund research for an eco-friendly
biofuel
[Music]
he also launched the Council of Elders a
crisis intervention dream team led by
Nelson Mandela I'd reached the age of 55
I've made
good money so I could pick up the phones
pretty well anybody and cut through and
get things done suddenly I was in a
position where I could maybe make a
difference in the world critics have
scoffed at the new socially minded
Branson and point to the offshore tax
shelters he has used for decades to
protect his wealth I don't think which
is any different to the other very very
wealthy businessmen who've got armies of
accountants and lawyers telling them you
know where to put their money where to
hide their money
is he the people's entrepreneur
only up to a point Branson hasn't been
able to safeguard all of his assets
Virgin America had a rough time getting
off the ground and lost nearly 400
million dollars before beginning to turn
a profit in the third quarter of 2010.
as he heads into his 60s it's been a
long and thrilling Journey for the
Virgin King
Francis made his own life I think he's
been very very good at it
so it's not just a golden touch I think
he's worked for it of course it's driven
by money but he's not impressed by
wealth
he's more bothered but to have fun and
don't have excitement you've got to have
the balance
I've been extraordinarily fortunate I've
enjoyed every minute of my life going
forward most of my time will be spent on
setting up not-for-profit Enterprises
and seeing them in attacking some of the
big big problems in the world
um but at the same time you know we will
still have wonderful adventures go go to
space go to the bottom of the oceans
and still push ourselves and challenge
my children and challenge the people
around me and have a blast
he's the Samurai warrior of Silicon
Valley Larry's attitude is if you want
to compete against me then be prepared
to be crushed
Larry Ellison started Oracle software
over 30 years ago and it has made him
the highest paid executive over the last
decade with a total compensation of 1.84
billion dollars there was nobody better
than Lariat making a customer believe
that he could change that person's
business life with his product he sees
around the corner well before many of us
get to the end of the street he'll do
whatever it takes to win in the office
sap the German software firm was ordered
to pay Oracle 1.3 billion dollars or on
the ocean there is absolutely no doubt
that he hates to lose his company's
technology has become the backbone of
the world's Information Systems from
government to online Commerce
the Brazen billionaire is an ambitious
provocateur with a singular management
style I have a theory that Larry's
succession plan for Oracle is he is
trying to figure out a way that when
he's six feet under in a grave he can
still run Oracle
Captain loud and clear okay
you know anything about oracle's Larry
Ellison it probably goes something like
this I've got a Bugatti the fastest car
in the world this home it costs 200
million dollars the fastest sailboat
that's ever been built I'm addicted to
winning the more you win the more you
want to win he's a high-flying
adrenaline junkie and an Unapologetic
collector of expensive toys and real
estate
spent 400 million dollars to bring the
2010 America's Cup the oldest active
trophy in sports back to America for the
first time in 15 years
[Applause]
but his success comes from something far
less flashy some of the world's most
Essential Software tools you use every
day but probably don't realize that it's
his company making them work
[Music]
almost everybody in the world uses
Oracle they just don't know it if you do
any kind of government transaction with
almost any government in the world any
business transaction with almost any
internet business in the world or any
traditional business if you have a
credit card if you have a cell phone if
you have any of the the modern things in
life if you live today I think you
probably use Oracle Larry Ellison
arguably created the most important
computer software you never heard of he
was the man behind the curtain for a
tremendous change in the way we all live
Ellison remained behind that curtain
when we tried to reach him to
participate in this program
born in the Bronx in 1944 Ellison grew
up in Chicago when he was 12 his father
bluntly gave him some surprising news my
dad just said right before dinner oh by
the way you were adopted and we're
having meatloaf tonight it was so
shocking I just put it away and thought
about it
for years
Without Really you know confronting all
and realizing all of the implications he
dropped out of college twice Ellison was
a mediocre student and disliked formal
education Mike Wilson is an editor for
the Saint Petersburg times and
interviewed Ellison extensively for his
biography Larry was not interested in
following the rules at school in the
family or anywhere else Larry needed to
get out from underneath the shadow of
Lewis Ellison and prove to his father
that he could make something of himself
his Flair for the fast lane was obvious
early Larry went out and bought himself
a turquoise blue Thunderbird he was a
stylish guy he wanted to impress people
he got in that car and he drove it to
California
Larry Ellison was a young man with a
great deal of potential his trip to
California was critical to who he would
become
Ellison settled in Berkeley and set out
to make a living writing code in 1973 he
worked at the computer electronics maker
amdov there he met Stewart Fagan they've
remained friends for over 35 years I
went into my cubicle on the first day I
worked there and across the hall were a
couple guys who never seemed to do any
work they just talked all the time and
one of them did nothing but talk about
himself how smart he was how stupid
everyone else was and how he really
ought to be running everything and that
was Larry Ellison Ellison was a talented
but impatient programmer desperate to
find something of his own to control
to say he he had the attention span of a
tumbleweed is to overestimate it I would
say more of the attention span of a
lightning bolt
but his attention focused when he landed
a job at a company called Ampex
Ampex was struggling with a project
funded by of all places the information
driven CIA the project was codenamed
Oracle the CIA needed a system to store
and retrieve vast amounts of foreign
intelligence concerned with its various
sensitive operations and missions for
Ellison it was the job of a lifetime and
would plant the seeds for his future
in the 1970s information storage meant
putting data on reel-to-reel tape which
was just too slow and inconsistent for
the CIA and too slow for Ellison he left
Ampex and later started his own company
with his friend and programming genius
Bob Miner Bob and Larry were a perfect
Odd Couple for Silicon Valley Bob had
all of the engineering smarts the
technical ability Larry on the other
hand had the sales ability the Visionary
ability the the ability to go to a
customer and explain here's how your
business can change with this original
handwritten sign and twelve hundred
dollars they started software
development Laboratories or sdl Ellison
recruited friends at Oates and Stuart
Fagan to help program he did want me to
join him and he's going to start some
kind of company and I thought that was
the stupidest idea I'd ever heard
because Larry wasn't famous for
finishing things I used to say he's a
total flake and he'll never amount to
anything and I was half right
Ellison's new company needed a product
and after reading an obscure IBM
research paper he thought he had it
a method of sorting information that was
vastly Superior to anything that had
come before it was called a relational
database according to Gary Bloom who
worked with Ellison for 14 years it was
a complex name but a simple idea
relational data is what you know what it
what is it it's a collection of data
information that's very simply put into
a format that makes it very easy to
search and find that information it's
nothing more complicated than that
IBM didn't see the potential of what
they had Ellison did I said oh my God we
can beat IBM to markets because IBM
doesn't believe in their own idea
Ellison believed and asked programmer
Bruce Scott to start writing code for me
it's just cool technology and kind of
fun but for Larry you know he saw a
company out of it he saw a market out of
it we weren't sure Larry was right but
we needed the jobs and it was a struggle
all the time Larry was was under a lot
of pressure to get some money in somehow
in 1977 at age 34 Larry Ellison's
startup software company was busy
creating a smart database they thought
would revolutionize how companies
retrieve manage and analyze data three
rooms and a little lobby area there were
four of us who were writing programs
Larry was mostly involved in finding
customers
and that was a bizarre idea because we
had no software so all the things that
you would read in books of somebody
being a leader he wasn't but he was
tenacious he would never give up on
anything
Allison chased and cajoled customers
becoming the company's Chief evangelist
there was nobody better than Lariat
making a business person making a
customer believe that he could change
that person's business life with his
product
knowing they still needed a smarter
solution for the Monumental task of
managing worldwide intelligence Ellison
sold his database to the CIA his first
customer he called the new software
Oracle version 2. there was no version
one because everyone thought well no one
buys version one it's buggy so we
started with version two well our
version two was at least as buggy as
anyone's version one and I described
those early versions as the roach motel
of databases the data went in but it
didn't come out in 1982 Ellison also
took the name Oracle for his company he
targeted government agencies and major
corporations in his own unique way I
remember him telling me very distinctly
one time Bruce we can't be successful
unless we lie to customers for some
reason Larry told the Bank of America I
think he told us there were 15 of us
when in fact there were five of us I'm
not sure why the Bank of America would
think differently of you if you're 5 or
15. but Larry had given them a number
which was a little larger than reality
Allison also was sharpening a sales
philosophy rooted in a trip he had taken
to Japan in the early 1970s I was in
Japan and I was talking to a Japanese
business executive and uh
he told me uh
you know that the problem with America
is that we just have no stomach for
competition in Japan we believe our
competitors are stealing the rice out of
the mouths of our you know of our
children in Japan we think anything less
than 100 market share is not enough
his take no prisoners approach became
known as the Oracle way the Oracle way
in the early to mid 80s was just to win
almost by any means necessary
Larry's attitude is if you want to
compete against me then you better be
prepared to be crushed or don't compete
against me his product the Oracle
database took off like a jet fighter in
one of his ads and in 1986 Oracle went
public his 39 stake in the company was
worth a stunning 93 million dollars the
IPO was a huge hit but was overshadowed
the very next day by Microsoft's public
offering which made Bill Gates steak
worth a whopping 350 million dollars
in 1989 Ellison moved Oracle to this
Mammoth campus in Redwood Shores
California which became known as the
Emerald City a reference to The Wizard
of Oz or as one newspaper described it
larryland and everyone knew who was The
Wizard when I ordered a Ferrari 348 and
I was going to get the first 348 in
California
Larry ordered one from somewhere on the
east coast and got it shipped in before
I got mined he didn't want to be the
second one he wanted to be the first one
his obsession to be first took its toll
Oracle hit a wall these aggressive sales
practices started to cause serious
problems oracle's aggressive sales
practices in the 80s turned the company
into an accountant's nightmare
the Salesforce was so aggressive so
willing to close the deal and there were
so few business controls over the makeup
of those deals then we started having
the problem of we certainly signed some
bad contracts they were also selling
products that hadn't yet been created
Oracle was selling a lot of Futures so
you were taking a lot of money and a lot
of Revenue in for future deliverables
well then the question comes when you
finally have those deliverables now who
do you sell them to you already sold it
to everybody you sold it to them three
years before you had it it didn't help
the company's prospects that their
latest product was a dud Oracle version
6 was riddled with bugs customers were
frustrated and sales plummeted
it's sometimes characterized as the
near-death experience of Oracle in the
early 90s and it was we weren't cutting
fat we're cutting into muscle and you
might even say we're in a couple cases
we're cutting a couple limbs off
with oracle's stock price and Free Fall
so was Ellison's personal Fortune by
November 1st 1990 he had lost 790
million dollars
his company was nearly a billion dollar
operation and it was failing Larry was
trying to achieve this greatness he was
building towards that all the time and
now he was in a sense a laughing stock
it was devastating for him we're all a
bunch of kids that grew up with the
business
and uh we weren't kids anymore and the
business wasn't a little business
anymore it was big business and we had
to replace virtually all of Senior
Management and it was a very painful
process
he convinced well-known management and
sales consultant Ray Lane to join the
company
and what he brought was what I'd
characterize as operational discipline
and a maturity around this is how a big
business runs it was chaotic it was
painful nobody wanted to go through that
again and so the culture was kind of
reset
but the company's real savior came in
the form of a new product
Zach Nelson was oracle's youngest
marketing executive Oracle 7 was a
spectacular product the future was
incredibly bright and I think everybody
within Oracle at that time certainly
knew it and can sense it it wasn't just
incrementally better it was orders of
magnitude better
Ellison's company had dodged its
near-death experience in 1994 Oracle
revenues passed the two billion dollar
Mark and his stock as a result was worth
nearly three billion dollars
for Ellison that wasn't nearly enough to
become software's Soul heavyweight
Ellison knew he had to pick a fight with
the reigning Champion Bill Gates she
seemed to be personally disappointed he
wasn't wealthier than Bill Gates it's
the scorecard and if you weren't number
one if you weren't richest you weren't
on the top you weren't the best it was
the scorecard and he was losing
I think that Larry thought he was in a
tremendous competition with Bill Gates
and and maybe Gates didn't think so so
much Larry wanted to be recognized as
the greatest innovator salesman
evangelist in the world of software and
he had a steep battle going up against
the guy who had put his software in
every single personal computer
practically in the world
[Music]
Allison was fixated on Gates he would
later admit publicly to hiring private
detectives to dig up dirt on him
Gates's new product Windows 95 had the
entire Tech World buzzing including
Ellison himself in this appearance on
the Charlie Rose show
this Windows 95 is an enormously
complicated piece of software and the
idea of the people to install this in
their households and manage these things
in their household to me is hilarious
and it's time for something that's
easier this is clearly part of our
strategy to throw in Microsoft but the
way you determined Microsoft is not
somebody that you know to throw darts at
Bill Gates and hate and envy Bill Gates
you have to think about think about
products and create products that are
better than their products that
Microsoft is selling
Ellison made a move into the consumer
device Market
called it the network computer or NC
he launched the network computer with
great Fanfare the computers we currently
make personal computers are rather
expensive right very very complex so
we've introduced this new classic
computer and for normal human beings
it's very long it's pretty very low cost
very lightweight yeah every person can
use a computer because they're low cost
and very easy to use you can surf the
net you can do email on and he said and
it could be 500 it's kind of an Internet
Appliance so to speak no different than
your toaster I can remember having a
discussion with him saying you know the
internet makes it possible to imagine a
world without Microsoft's operating
system on every desktop and that was
really you know the birth of the NC
Ellison went on a campaign to promote
the power of his new baby on the web
while mocking the popular PC
I hate the PC
with a passion put the stuff on the net
it's bits don't put bits in cardboard
cardboard and trucks trucks to stores me
go to the store you know pick this stuff
out it's insane I love the internet
but Falling PC prices meant the NC was
destined to fail
I don't think there was anything wrong
with the idea I actually just think it
was premature five years later would
have won the world and the only
difference is all the PC manufacturers
Dell HP everybody else Gateway what did
they do they created a 500 PC that surfs
the web really well and it does email
really well
and that shut down Ellison's Venture
into the consumer Market
his NC was too far ahead of its time but
his vision of the internet was still
right on target
oracle's database became the
underpinnings of all of these internet
services that we take for granted today
it was Expedia Amazon eBay go down the
list of applications all of those are
storing all that information retrieving
that information delivering that
information doing those transactions
through the Oracle database people
thought Larry was crazy now he's a
genius kind of solved the biggest I.T
problem in history by 2000 Larry
Ellison's company Oracle was among the
elite tech companies in the world
but internal struggles would soon Force
out the company's president and Chief
Operating Officer Ray Lane who had risen
to second in command and Heir Apparent
he described the culture at the company
he left wasn't good enough for a
Salesman to make their quota
they had to make 200 percent of their
quota
it was you know the top 10 percent get
rewarded millions and everybody else you
know Falls by the webs they're weak
soldiers shoot them
a departing Lane said he didn't fit into
oracle's system and that the only person
making decisions at Oracle is Larry lots
of people that transitioned in and out
of Oracle got confused who was in charge
and that's a pretty volatile that's like
a galactic Collision you know where two
stars hit and it's a pretty violent
explosion
Oracle the company was on a roll but was
lagging behind in one key area we're
still fighting to be relevant in the
applications World we're the number two
application provider in the world and
we're number two in Erp behind sap boy
this number two is getting old and we're
number two not for long we're number two
we're number two in uh CRM behind siebel
but we're growing faster than sap and
we're growing faster than siebel and
we're determined to become number one in
applications as like we're number one in
database to get to number one Ellison
needed to do something his company had
long avoided buying new technology
through Acquisitions when he came to
that conclusion he opened his wallet and
far bigger than anyone else did and in
fact he did it far faster than anyone
else did Ellison wanted to bundle new
application software with oracle's
successful product line in 2003 he
targeted the company PeopleSoft in a
hostile takeover attempt
the Department of Justice sued Oracle on
antitrust grounds charging the Takeover
would empower the company to illegally
raise rates and impair innovation
after a year and a half long battle the
courts sided with Oracle Ellison finally
acquired PeopleSoft for 10.3 billion
dollars
very rare that someone gets sued by the
government and they actually win you
know I mean it's just another Testament
to this guy's tenacity most guys would
have maybe walked away from that instead
Ellison stepped it up over the next five
years he would spend close to 34 billion
dollars acquiring 52 companies Heather
bellini is senior managing director of
the technology research team at
International strategy and Investment
Group she has covered Oracle since 2003.
he started looking out and seeing how
the landscape was was changing and how
the Carnage that was done to some of his
competitors and was going to give him an
opportunity to go make some Acquisitions
and buy some technology where he was
behind and he really was the one that
started the whole m a trend within the
technology industry
Ellison's appetite for Acquisitions
accelerated in 2009 with his 7.4 billion
dollar trophy purchase of the prominent
hardware company Sun Microsystems
but in 2010 his eyes were on another
trophy a decade-long 400 million dollar
obsession
BMW Oracle racing was launched in 2000
for Ellison's run at the Americas cup it
may be the oldest active prize in
international sport but what Ellison
created was entirely new the boat is a
trimaran it often appears to be nearly
flying with only one of its three hulls
actually in contact with the water
[Music]
the oceans have never seen anything like
it
there is absolutely no doubt that he
hates to lose there's no doubt of that
at all Grant Dalton has competed against
Ellison on the America's Cup circuit my
recollection and racing against him and
we will race against him in the future
this is a man that's very determined to
win
on Valentine's Day 2010 Allison brought
the Americas cup back to the United
States for the first time in 15 years
he celebrated with his now ex-wife
romance novelist Melanie Kraft it was
his fourth marriage
Samurai Warrior re-emerged when his
friend Mark Hurd resigned as CEO at
Hewlett-Packard amid allegations of
sexual harassment and expense account
irregularities
Ellison was outraged he attacked the HP
board of directors he said quote the HP
board just made the worst Personnel
decision since the idiot on the apple
board fired Steve Jobs many years ago
exactly one month later Ellison stunned
the business world when he turned around
and hired the ousted executive
the Silicon Valley soap opera continued
when HP named Leo appetaker as its chief
executive his former company sap is
oracle's biggest rival in business
software
sap and Oracle had been locked in a
nasty three-year copyright infringement
case that ended in November 2010.
P the German software firm was ordered
to pay Oracle 1.3 billion dollars it was
the biggest settlement ever for software
piracy
Larry Ellison's brawl had drawn New
Blood on the information technology
Battlefield and as always he is more
determined than ever to win Larry
Ellison is
pretty similar to the New York Yankees
they're the team you love to hate and as
a competitor to Larry Ellison I'm sure
he's the person that people love to hate
just given how successful he's been
While most Visionaries you think are
sort of just talking off their hat and
saying okay this is how the world can be
you know Larry sees how the world can be
and then he actually tries to make it
that
he started with a 1200 stake in a little
company and by sheer force of will and
persuasion he built it into one of the
giant software companies of the world
[Music]